endlich wird der neue geh und radweg im
oberbayerischen gmund am tegernsee
an dieser gemeinde straße gebaut aber
irgendwie sieht die baustelle zwischen
finsterwald und dürnbach doch ziemlich
seltsam aus mitten im schönen radweg
neubau frank diese saftig grüne wiese
radler müssen deshalb wieder auf die
straße ausweichen
der grund der gemeinde gehören zwei
wichtige grundstücke gar nicht hier
fehlen hier 30 meter und ein stück
weiter gar 100 meter baugrund
unglaublich es ist gut dass mal jemand
das angeht dass ein radweg dahin kommt
aber dass er in der hälfte aufhört dass
wir schon ziemlicher blödsinn
als er wolle für liste sind richtig
sowas wollen weg vorher gesagt habe dass
hätten einmal vorher abgeklärt und nicht
einfach bohrungen wenn jetzt auch
unterbrechungen sind ist die sache
völlig unsinnig aber vielleicht hat die
gemeinde einfach nur vergessen die
grundstücke zu kaufen
wir rufen im rathaus an und fragen was
denn da schiefgegangen ist
doch obwohl der radweg mit satten
242.000 euro steuergeldern finanziert
wird hält es der bürgermeister nicht für
nötig sich zu erklären möglicherweise
ist den verantwortlichen ihr planungs
desaster auch einfach nur zu peinlich
denn landwirte waren schlicht nicht
bereit ihre wiesen der gemeinde zu
verkaufen
trotzdem hat man in gmund schon mal
munter angefangen zu bauen
nach dem motto wird schon irgendwie gut
gehen das ergebnis dieser absurde
flickenteppich wir wollen persönlich im
rathaus nachfragen
doch die gemeinde kommt ihrer
auskunftspflicht nicht nach und ein
interview gibt es schon gar nicht nur
dieser durchsatz erreicht uns per mail
die gemeinde gmund befindet sich derzeit
in laufenden grundstücksverhandlungen
und wird deshalb keine stellungnahme
abgeben
aha aber verhandelt man nicht besser
über die grundstücke bevor man etwas
baut viele gmünder bürger finden dass
bau chaos absurd
dies ist eine schildbürgerstreich ist
eigentlich schade dass es so gekommen
ist
die fronten zwischen den landwirt munter
gemeinde sind völlig verhärtet
in nächster zeit wird sich hier
vermutlich nichts mehr tun
radler und fußgänger werden sie auch
weiterhin in den laufenden autoverkehr
stürzen müssen
und so bleibt der gmunder lücken weg
auch in zukunft ein reichlich sinnlose
attraktion im alpenvorland